MANO MARKS: Hi, Mano
Marks, developer advocate
on the Google Maps API team.
This is the third
video in a series
of four designed to show you how
to get started with the Google
Maps JavaScript API.
In the last video, I
covered getting an API key
for the Google Maps
JavaScript API.
In this video, we'll
cover using the key
when loading the JavaScript
API and the basics
of using the Google Maps Loader.
The Google Maps JavaScript API
is loaded using a script tag.
The basic format
looks like this.
You can see that there
are two parameters,
both required if you're
going to use an API key.
A common mistake people
make is to copy and paste
this text without
changing the parameters.
The Maps API will not
load in this case.
First, replace API
key with your API key,
and then set the sensor
to either true or false.
In most cases, it
will probably false.
For example, look at this.
This will pass both
the key and tell Google
whether you are creating
a map that uses a sensor
to detect the
location of the user.
A note on the sensor
parameter-- you must set this
to true or false,
but it doesn't change
the capabilities
of the Maps API.
If you are using a sensor,
there's no additional data
that you get.
There's no costs
associated with it.
And likewise if you're not.
We must collect this
information to provide back
to our data providers.
That's the only
reason we collect it.
There are a few optional
parameters though,
that you should be aware of.
The first is a
language parameter.
By specifying the
language parameter,
you are changing
the default language
of the map, both the map
tiles and the controls.
In this example, by using JA,
we change the map to Japanese.
We support both left to right
and right to left languages.
For instance, if you
chose AR for Arabic,
you will see right to left.
When you do this, however, you
should specify DIR equals RTO
in the div containing
any RTL text.
Lastly, we also include
a libraries parameter.
This is to load in the Google
Maps API libraries that
provide additional
functionality to the API
but should only be loaded
if they are required.
For more information, see
the libraries documentation
at this URL.
That's all for this episode.
In the next episode, we'll
cover the basic Maps options
used to create your first map.